foreign
let's go to Amanda in Madison Wisconsin
what's up Amanda
hi John how are you today I'm good how
are you
know I'm I'm living the dream right
hey I'm running I'm running a scam they
call a podcast here so I can't really
talk I'm having fun so what's up
the reason I'm calling you today is
because I'm trying to figure out how to
help best my son or how to best help my
son who is he's a sixth grader first you
know first year in middle school and
he's experiencing something like on
bouts of on and off anxiety to the point
where it's like manifesting in
physical like headaches and feeling sick
and things like that where he's having a
hard time
getting through his day and
I'm trying to figure out how to help him
get through these these things that he's
going through is this new or has this
been going on a long time
it has been going on
for the summer he really wanted to play
tackle football with his friends
and we got him into that and after a
couple of weeks he was getting
um
physical like hip pains or back pains
where he felt like he couldn't practice
he was couldn't play in football then
you know so I'd take him to practice to
let him watch and learn still but then
the coaches were saying that he was you
know screwing around or playing on
playing around on the sidelines and and
doing things that if he's you know he's
not appearing to be actually hurt
um and so then I was able to figure out
from him after some conversations that
he was scared about getting tackled and
getting hurt at football practice and we
were able to then work through those
issues with the coaches and you know
with some extra time with the coaches he
was able to work through that and finish
the season but
yeah so that's another instance where he
had like I don't know if that was
anxiety or if it was just fear or if it
I don't
yeah piercing's hard man
I I don't see a lot of utility in trying
to parse the difference
okay
um whether it's fear or anxiety and what
type of anxiety it is
um sometimes it's helpful to name the
dragon but generally speaking your son's
body is telling him
to opt out of a situation
and right it has determined that going
to school is not a safe situation it's
determined that playing football is not
a safe situation and since he doesn't
seem to be able to get the signals it's
going to start manifesting pain and hurt
and all kinds of things that have a
weird self-reinforcement to them because
that's when people lean in and say are
you okay
and they listen to him and they hear him
and his body goes oh thank God
and I'm seen and I'm heard finally and
then it reinforces okay that's how we
get that sort of connection there
so backing out
um these are always hard questions and
they're not supposed to be accusatory
okay this is just data collection do you
and your husband have anxious Tendencies
to like where is
where is this anxiety coming from did he
get hurt somewhere did he watched one of
his football friends just get leveled is
he getting bullied at school where does
this originate from
I I don't personally suffer from any
like anxious Tendencies my husband does
okay
um he did see one of his teammates get
hurt at football practice and that kind
of I think where some of that stemmed
from sure at school he was diagnosed
last year with dyslexia okay
um and so he struggles with keeping
things straight in his mind and gets
overwhelmed when he because they use
Google classroom and so he can see all
the different assignments that they're
going to work on for that given day and
then he sees how many he's got and then
he gets overwhelmed of oh my gosh I have
so much to do well but also with
dyslexia
he gets a reinforcement on a daily basis
that he's stupid
and that he's and that he's different he
does I bet he does
one of the most common responses I've
had with young working with young people
with dyslexia is a reinforcement that
everybody's going faster than they are
and that it's become something's wrong
with them
and it's a message that schools pass
along not unintentionally maybe not with
your particular sub man I've just heard
that over and over yeah
and that was something that I worried
about getting you know because I had him
assessed for some you know just because
I knew he was struggling and I wanted to
know why I wanted to know what it was
and I wanted to know how to help him and
the dyslexia diagnosis was at least
something to be like okay now wait let's
how do we work around this and it hasn't
been anything
that
I've noticed that he he's he's been able
to really adapt to it and work around it
but he's not he's not his body's not
this isn't an intellectual exercise his
body is telling him he's not okay
let me ask you this what you need to get
him into a third
what's your what's your husband's
avoidance strategies when he gets
anxious how does he get out of
situations
um
he when he does when he's uncomfortable
he pretty much just quit
so he exits the building
yeah okay children are unable to do that
because they don't have car keys they
don't have control they don't have
autonomy
and so kids bodies revolt
does that make sense
so I just want you to think of your son
as a little boy
whose body is telling him he's not safe
and he can't leave
and I'm not saying to run and leave okay
right so
let me back out this way the first thing
I want you to do is I want you to
believe him
okay
believe him that he hurts understand
that
um some folks have really tall kids some
folks have short kids some folks have
kids with lots my friends used to make
call me guaca when I was a kid because I
had lots of moles right some like
whatever dude like there's all kinds of
things that parents like their kids are
born with you your kid might have a
a heightened a heightened sensitivity in
his amygdala that doesn't mean he's
sensitive and he not like that just his
body experiences things in an amplified
way particularly anxiety that's it right
his amygdala is Uber reactive that's all
okay so what we're going to teach him
over a period of time is
when that system goes off and says
you're not safe
every kid watched their buddy get
smashed on that football field
your kid's alarm system was just louder
than theirs does that make sense
so what we're going to do is we're going
to teach them both and
and it's going to be really tough
because his brain has to learn that this
is the alarm system and we can do it
anyway
and not only can we do it anyway but on
the other side of doing it and
accomplishing it and and getting these
little wins
it's going to feel infinitely better
than the cheap winds we're getting every
time we avoid something
accomplishment is going to feel better
than this headache does that make sense
yes and so
what does care look like in your home or
let me ask this direct do you all have a
special time where you have one-on-one
time where there's 30 minutes and
there's no phone and you ask him how his
day went you'll color together you'll
draw all together you'll do Legos
together do you have any type of system
like that
we typically on the weekends will do
like family game night or something like
that I mean it's not an every we don't
get time every day to do something but
we usually on the weekends are able to
set some time and do family game night
okay so there's this it's out of the
conscious discipline literature but it's
called two good choices and we're going
to teach this young man some autonomy
but it's going to be bounded autonomy
meaning you're going to give them a
couple of ideas
and I want you to and your husband to
make some schedule some time in your
schedule three times a week not
including the weekends it could be
breakfast time I take my son to
breakfast once a week is it convenient
no do I have time for it really no
it's become one of my favorite moments
of my life
and sometimes we only get 30 minutes at
Waffle House I get 30 minutes of time
with him and diabetes but we go right we
do it every every once a week
but I want y'all to pencil in 30 minutes
where there's no phones there's no
screens there is nothing but connection
and I want you to give him you want to
do Legos together or do you want to do
fill in the blank together
and he gets to pick which one of those
things he gets to enter into
and you're not going to try to solve
anything you're not going to try to
coach him on anything you're just going
to practice being with
and my guess is it's a crazy guess but
my guess is over time his body's going
to
oh I don't know how that I didn't know
how that felt that feels really good
I like this relationship connectivity
does that make sense
and
in the meantime if he doesn't want to
play football that's fine
um my friend Lane Norton just won World
Championships in weightlifting if him
and I were working out together and he
lifted his reps and I got under the bar
I'd have to take a lot of weight off
because I'm just not that strong yet
yeah like I did that I'll never be as
strong as it is Lane
um but I would have to take some weight
off because I'm not there yet I'm
practicing training
and similarly he's in sixth grade he's
got a potentially a very reactive
amygdala great if he comes home and says
whoa I just saw one of my classmates get
depleted and his nose got broken and I
don't really want to play football
anymore say okay
you have to choose because we're going
to do one outdoor thing
you got to pick one thing
and you can choose from soccer or
baseball but you're going to do a thing
but you don't have to play football and
we're not cashing out we're not wimping
out we're not he's got to choose another
activity he can't just go home and play
video games or whatever but we're going
to slowly teach him that okay
you're learning we're going to practice
something else then and we're just going
to do that with if he gets an 88 that's
fine for now right what is he nervous
about at school
um like what's the failure he's sensing
there why is his body not want him in
that building
I haven't been able to really pinpoint I
think it's just the whole the
overwhelmed because he's being graded
for Rio now on classes like he can get
he can get enough he can fail stuff for
like um yeah but where does he get the
sense that a failure is the end of
something
is that from you and your husband is I
put a lot of pressure on my kids to do
well academically so I'm not saying it's
a bad thing except from y'all is it from
school where is it from
I'm not sure I mean we we don't
we don't
um
pressure him to get like he doesn't have
to be a straight A student we always
have always taught our kids to you know
just try your best and if that's the
best that you you can do then
as long as you tried your best we're
okay with that he's actually getting
he's actually a straight A student
um but he's he is smart he's not
um
he's not failing it's just I don't know
if the pressure of I I don't know I
don't know why he
is so afraid of his grades or having
late homework you know if he has
something that he doesn't get done in
class and he ends up having to take it
home to do homework it gives he just
worries about it
okay
and I don't know why
my guess is he's always been able to
help I've always been able to help him
do his homework at home and we always
get it done but like when he's at school
and it's not done he worries about it
foreign
yeah that sounds so Environmental
it sounds so environmental I I would I
would strongly recommend
um you
you go with him
and don't ship him off to a counselor
just go sit and see a counselor but you
go with him
because I think what I'm guessing is
there are some strategies inside your
home
that when he gets home there is a
there's a heightened level of tension
there and it could be from husband it
could be from
um the way he is perceiving things it
could be from you it could be from any
number of things but somehow he has
picked up his body has picked up the
and over Amplified these signals that
he's not safe
and it's going to give him a stomach
ache it's going to give him a headache
it's going to give him these things
right I think seeing a counselor would
be wise because hearing it from a third
party adult
who is trained at listening and being
quiet and leaning in and making
connections with a kid
um they may even have him do his sixth
grades they may have him do some play
therapy maybe a little bit aged out of
that a little bit but maybe not
um
but another adult might be able to give
him some strategies give you some
strategies give you all some new
language together
but I'm gonna double back my guess is
this is a highly highly relational I'd
want to know if he's getting bullied at
school if school is somehow unsafe I
would really have a counselor dig into
the dyslexia and how that makes him feel
in relationship to his other classmates
um and it may be that dyslexia was part
of the diagnostic and there's more who
knows
but I want to start at home with the
things you can control and that is I'm
going to put everything away I'm going
to create space in my day and by the way
I'm not going to say I've made time for
you or I could do that
I'm just going to create space
an anxious kid is highly highly
perceptive for safety
and I want you to create as safe as
environment as possible and that's going
to come from presence so let's start
there let's get him into a counselor
um let me say it this way your kid's not
broken
he's not broken let's give him some
autonomy to make some choices about an
actor out an outdoor activity
um about does he want to do his homework
right now or do you want to do that
let's give him teach him autonomy
just teach him slowly how to do hard
things
and a good counselor is going to help
you all walk through re basically
retraining his brain neurological
training for feeling that alarm go off
really loud louder than his peers
fan still heading in
getting those accomplishments
but screaming at him beating him up and
I know you don't do those things but
that doesn't help that doesn't that's
not a thing
and it may be time for Dad to work on
his anxiety too because there's going to
come a point if he's not there already
where your son's gonna feel responsible
for making sure Dad doesn't feel anxious
then that is a burden that no sixth
grader no kid can carry thank you so
much for your calling for loving that
kid man